at the end of the last animation I asked
you to share your own stories of uneven
understanding share you did more than I
could have imagined we built one of the
web's largest collection of asymmetric
intelligibility stories right there in
the comments you also called me out
could I maybe share something personal
about my journey into language that's
something patrons have asked for too
since we have a bit of downtime today's
a good day to do that in my life
there hasn't just been one thing that
connected me to language it's been a
bunch of small moments little
experiences some of these end up in my
videos so I guess keep watching to get
the full story but if I'm sharing
personal experiences it might have to be
this one it's not what I expected today
but there are events struggles things in
my earlier life I wouldn't be here
without these are my scars literal scars
at the time it's so superficial but as a
kid I was kind of shy it's something I
slowly grew out of thanks to a happy
family team sports great friends until I
ran into that life wall called
adolescence that means different things
to different teens I got some of the
normal awkwardness and acne but on top
of that I began to get serious scabs and
rashes and worse all over my face my
hands my neck I tried to cover it up or
at least play it off I couldn't always
find ways to cope I'd make it through a
school day and I'd rushed to be alone
study or draw or ride my bike off on my
own on tough days I remember sitting
behind bus benches instead of waiting up
front like a normal person just so my
latest scars weren't out there for
everyone to see why am I telling you
this
because it mattered I was uncomfortable
and struggling to find worth in my own
skin and that made it tough to connect
super
officially I had to look past my skin
and lean on ways I knew to connect on a
deeper level I did this with language
it helped me relate to people people
with their own scars people who past and
present open up and shared stories of
languages and cultures with me they gave
me riches more meaningful than if I'd
never had this struggle eventually it
took years but eventually I got a
diagnosis my skin was sensitive to
fragrances laundry deodorant cologne
shampoo hair products washing dishes
they were all leaving scars I made
changes and the scars healed that's what
they do I remember the day my mom helped
me take off my sheets and wash
everything in fragrance free detergent I
got to leave it behind usually for my
skin and definitely for my mind what
clocks tick and scars fade I get to make
up for lost time for the most part I've
moved on which is one reason why these
videos take a while
yes animation is a thing that takes time
I've learned how true that is
but there's more to my story in an
effort to be a productive part of our
future world and pay for those hand
baskets of food I've been on my own
years long journey to be a better
programmer maybe a bit later in life
than I expected but well you've been
watching I've been putting in the work
taking classes getting certified coding
projects this balancing act doesn't pay
well but in many other ways it's been
rewarding it even shapes the videos you
watch now the part of my journey that
would become native Lane is another
story when I shared with patrons but I'm
compelled to keep coming back partly
because of those earlier days when
language distracted me from my scars
well I've talked about where I've been
what about you what is language meant to
you was there a little moment or a
meaningful experience
I offer patrons much gratitude for all
your support and thank you for sticking
around and subscribing for language
[Music]
you